FITZ: We're back.
And we're here to talk about the
history of I/O with some
people who have been to a
number of Google I/Os.
BEN: And I know that you and
I, Fitz, have been to every
single Google I/O. So
we've watched it
evolve over the years.
We're going to talk to some
people who have also been here
from early days, and get their
opinions on how I/O has
changed over time.
FITZ: Absolutely.
So, hi.
What's your name?
KEVIN NILSON: Yeah,
I'm Kevin Nilson.
I'm the VP of Engineering
at just.me.
And just.me is a start up in the
mobile social space that's
inside of Google Startup Labs
funded by Google Ventures and
many others.
And one of the other things that
I do is I'm the leader
the Silicon Valley Google
Developer Group.
FITZ: So our viewers here have
seen you quite a bit in the
countdown to I/O lately.
Tell us a little more
about that.
KEVIN NILSON: Yeah, there was a
nice blog series with a lot
of us that kind of highlighted
some of our past experiences,
because we've got experiences in
a lot of I/Os, and kind of
what we were excited about
coming in to I/O. And I think
it's going to be a really
great event so far.
BEN: So this is the fifth Google
I/O. And you were here
for the very first.
Can you tell us what brought you
in to begin with and what
that experience was like--
FITZ: What was it like, yeah?
BEN: --back in 2008?
KEVIN NILSON: So I've always
really been inspired by Google
and what they do.
And I think I/O is a
really great thing.
Starting from the early days and
watching it grow to what
it's become today--
there's an interesting quote
from Tor on the Android
Eclipse team.
And what he said is that I/O
today is a lot like JavaOne in
the glory days.
And a lot of great
announcements, new releases,
new things that we're
all excited
about are being launched.
And I really feel that momentum,
being a long time a
veteran of JavaOne and seeing
this grow to what that wishes
it could be.
FITZ: Well, you worked with
a ton of different Google
technologies.
Tell us a little bit about some
of the technologies you
worked with when you were
coming to the first I/O.
KEVIN NILSON: So when I first
started with I/O, I was very
excited about Google Maps.
There was a lot of great
things with Maps.
I think a lot of Web 2.0 was
defined by Maps and what was
done in Google Maps.
And then, as things progressed,
I started doing
more HTML5 and working
with Chrome.
And those topics were
very interesting.
And then today, I spent--
I think almost every session
I've been to, maybe every
session I've been to, has
been Android related.
So I think the timeliness
of all the
sessions at Google I/O--
and now, I imagine next year,
and maybe the rest of this
I/O, I'll be attending a lot of
the cloud computing topics
that are out there.
BEN: I was going to say, so
what are you hoping to see
more of next year at I/O?
What are you looking
forward to?
KEVIN NILSON: It's hard
to say what I'll be
doing a year from now.
But I know today I think
the Jelly Bean
stuff is really exciting.
Kind of one of the things that
was just amazing for me was
some of the stuff that they
launched around the ability to
inject things into the back
stack, often notifications.
And that's something that I
spent the last month on and
off whiteboarding a solution
on how I thought
I could solve that.
And then here, that's been
rolled right into the API,
because I guess others
have been having the
same problems as me.
And I'm excited to go back and
just utilize what I learned.
BEN: That's fantastic.
Wow.
FITZ: So we've started off
with the first year that
there's been some great
giveaways, some interesting
pieces of hardware.
Have you gotten your bag
of awesome hardware?
What are you excited
about with that?
KEVIN NILSON: Yeah, there's
a lot of neat things.
So the Galaxy Nexus
is really great.
So I actually got a
few months ago.
I ordered it out of Europe.
It's extremely fast.
I love that.
And then, last night I was
actually up until 2:30 in the
morning taking our app at
just.me and trying to run it
on the Nexus 7.
And it was kind of great to see
that fully enriched, kind
of larger, seven-inch display
and what it can
bring for the future.
BEN: Do you have any plans to be
a tester for Google Glass?
KEVIN NILSON: Well, I haven't
ordered one yet.
But I'm keeping my
fingers crossed.
Maybe I'll get one some day.
But all the great giveaways--
what, for me, about the Nexus
7 that was really cool was
that it actually fits
in my pocket.
I'm not sure that it fits
in everyone's pocket.
But it's a tablet that
is small enough
to fit in my pocket.
BEN: Very convenient.
FITZ: We've been here
every year.
It feels to me like the
energy this year is
just off the charts.
Can you talk a little bit about
some of the things that
have changed and how
you've seen I/O
evolve over the years?
KEVIN NILSON: Yeah, I think
they've done a great job to
integrate all the partners.
And you go out into the demo
grounds, and there's so many
great things that people are
doing, innovative things on
top of Google technology.
And I think that's something
that's probably where I've
seen the most change from
the early I/Os.
There were virtually no booths,
nothing going on.
You could just see
the sessions.
And that was all.
And then, over time, there's
been more and more.
And today, it's almost
no Google
things out in that area.
So it's more the partners.
BEN: It's exciting to see the
ecosystem evolve, isn't it?
KEVIN NILSON: Absolutely.
BEN: It really is.
Great.
Well, thank you for chatting
with us here.
I think it's great to have
you here all these years.
And--
FITZ: Maybe we can talk to you
more next year at I/O '13.
KEVIN NILSON: I'm very excited
about Google I/O 2013.
FITZ: Thanks a lot, Kevin.
BEN: Thank you.
Hello again.
We've got another I/O attendee
here who's been
coming for a few years.
And what's your name?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Will Smidlein.
BEN: OK.
And Will, this is your second,
third, or something?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Third, yeah.
I started coming in 2010.
BEN: That's fantastic.
And how did you get into
programming to begin with?
WILL SMIDLEIN: When I was
really little, I was
exploring the web.
And I wanted to know how
websites worked.
So I went to the library and
grabbed a book on it and
figured it out.
And then after a little bit of
that, I decided to make them
functional, dynamic.
And so I started learning
languages like that.
And I saw I/O--
BEN: So, wait.
Way back there you
said library.
Is that like Wikipedia?
Is that some new thing?
WILL SMIDLEIN: At some
point in time, I
think there was books.
I don't know.
BEN: Made of trees?
That's crazy.
No.
So, you actually taught yourself
programming languages
on your own?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Yep.
Yeah, I've always taught myself
programming and every
new language I learn.
FITZ: So we couldn't help but
notice your name tag, which
you're not wearing at the
moment, said something that no
one else's name tags
here says.
Can you tell me what it says?
WILL SMIDLEIN: It says, youngest
developer at I/O.
FITZ: Youngest developer
at I/O. And
exactly how old are you?
WILL SMIDLEIN: I'm 15.
FITZ: So when you first
came here, you were?
WILL SMIDLEIN: 13--
12?
BEN: 12.
FITZ: So that's pretty
incredible.
What kind of advice would you
have for other people who are
12, 13, 14, 15 for coming to
I/O, or getting involved in
programming, or anything
like that?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Just
start programming.
I mean, do it fun.
Don't worry about making a
product or making a name for
yourself or anything.
I mean, you don't really
have to worry about it
until you're older.
So just learn while you can.
I mean, that's why I'm here.
I'm here to learn.
FITZ: So follow what you're
interested in?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Exactly.
FITZ: You came to the first I/O,
second-- well, not the
first I/O, but your first I/O.
Tell me a little bit about
what that felt like, your
first time here.
WILL SMIDLEIN: Well, it was
pretty incredible, because the
I/O staff made a specific
exception to let me come as
long as I brought
my dad along.
And I just sat in awe at the
first keynote as they
announced all these things
that I was used
to reading on blogs.
And I was right there.
And it's always amazing to me
what they come up with next
year and next year and
the year after that.
And it's pretty crazy.
BEN: Now, do you have any
friends that you do
programming with?
Is it purely a solo activity
right now?
WILL SMIDLEIN: No.
I mean, one of the main reasons
I come to I/O is to
meet up with all the people
from GitHub, and IRC, and
Twitter, and put faces with
the names beyond Twitter
profile pictures, and just
interact with people.
BEN: Yeah, it's great to see
people in real life.
I've found the same
at conferences.
It's a big deal.
At this year's conference, are
there particular areas that
you've been listening in
on or learning from?
WILL SMIDLEIN: I'm really
excited about the stuff that
Google is doing with the cloud,
cloud computing, all
those cores.
This morning, for the demo,
that was pretty crazy.
So I'm interested to see how
that's going to work out for
development purposes.
BEN: Do you have any ideas on
what to do with all those
cores, crazy ideas?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Calculate
all of pi.
BEN: All of it.
WILL SMIDLEIN: All of it.
BEN: That's going to take
a little while.
FITZ: A lot of our viewers out
there will know that they've
seen you on the countdown to
I/O. So you were involved in
some of that stuff.
Tell me a little more about
your countdown to I/O.
WILL SMIDLEIN: So before I/O,
I got a nice little email
saying, hey, do you want
to be part of this?
And I said, sure.
I kind of want to give an
intro, and get other
developers excited for I/O.
Because it is exciting.
FITZ: What are some of the
most exciting things this
year, other than, of course,
people jumping out of blimps
with Glass on their face?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Like I said,
the cloud computing, the
Google Glass.
You know, actually being able
to pre-register for that is
pretty cool.
FITZ: Now, did you pre-register
for that?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Well,
of course.
FITZ: Do you have
a credit card?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Maybe.
FITZ: OK.
All right.
WILL SMIDLEIN: And then the
Android, the Ice Cream
Sandwich, really cool the speed
that's coming with that.
FITZ: Jelly Bean?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Right, right.
I just said Ice Cream
Sandwich.
Some of the web stuff, the demos
today, just basically
everything.
FITZ: So it sounds like you've
really absorbed all the
conference.
You've got all the sessions.
You've got people you're
meeting up with.
WILL SMIDLEIN: Yeah.
That's why I come.
BEN: Do you have any advice for
other folks your age, I
guess, who want to get involved
in programming,
specific to this conference or
come to this conference?
Have you thought about
inviting other folks?
WILL SMIDLEIN: Yeah, I mean,
just start learning.
Pick a language.
Get really good at it.
Start making stuff with it.
And if you open source it,
show people you can code.
And people will take interest.
It's a very natural
progression.
BEN: I like that advice.
We're big open source
guys ourselves.
And so that's a great
way to get started.
We always talk about how it's
sort of the internship that
you get for free if you
participate in open source.
FITZ: When you're on the
internet programming, no one
knows that you're
14 years old.
BEN: Or a dog.
FITZ: Or a dog.
All right.
Thanks a lot, Will, for
coming to talk to us.
BEN: Great to meet you.
FITZ: We hope to see you
there next year.
WILL SMIDLEIN: OK.
Good.
FITZ: Take it easy.
Bye-bye.
OK, now we're here with
another Google Ion.
That is someone who has attended
all five Google I/Os.
And what's your name?
VINCENT NGUYEN: I'm Vincent
Nguyen, editor-in-chief of
SlashGear and Android
Community.
FITZ: Tell everybody about
SlashGear and Android Community.
VINCENT NGUYEN: SlashGear
is more of a tech site,
everything, review, news.
Android Community
is 24/7 Android.
So it started a little
bit before the
first Google I/O, obviously.
I remember when it was
the first event.
And people just walked in.
There was no queue.
And it was kind of cool.
Nowadays, you know, you've got
a queue of like six bazillion
people wrapped around
the building.
It's changed so much.
BEN: That's true.
And in 2008, Android was
pretty new, right?
And so your community was new.
VINCENT NGUYEN: [INAUDIBLE]
BEN: Yeah, it was barely
there, right?
So--
VINCENT NGUYEN: Exactly.
But we were there.
We were one of the first on
the internet writing about
Android, covering the news.
And it was kind of cool
to be a part--
to take part in history--
taking a part of something
that was really big.
And obviously now, with a
bazillion of these Androids
floating around-- and the whole
Jelly Bean is kind of
cool, because different colors,
different version of
Android, different devices,
tablet, phones, and whatnot.
So--
BEN: So you've really gotten to
watch Android evolve over
the years, not just in
the products, but
at the show as well.
VINCENT NGUYEN: Not just watch
but actively participating in
reviewing the different products
that's available
today, whether it's
a tablet, phone.
We've seen it grow
into Q, right?
I mean, it's such a cool
product that was just
announced yesterday.
FITZ: So what are some of the
great things you've seen this
year at I/O that have really
gotten you excited?
VINCENT NGUYEN: Well, first of
all, a bunch of dudes jumping
out of an airplane
wearing Glasses.
And we saw it live.
I mean, that's not something
we expected.
FITZ: I've got to say, I didn't
expect that either.
VINCENT NGUYEN: Yeah,
we didn't either.
Next year, I think the only
thing to top it would be like
a big pair of Glasses on
a self driving car.
FITZ: The car will drive
itself here.
VINCENT NGUYEN: Exactly,
on stage.
BEN: Can it navigate its way
down maybe on to the building
if we put a glider on it.
It could be good.
VINCENT NGUYEN: That
would be cool.
I would definitely
expect that.
FITZ: We can't do any
pre-announcements for 2013.
But we'll definitely put that
in the suggestion box.
VINCENT NGUYEN: Appreciate it.
BEN: So are you an Android
developer yourself?
VINCENT NGUYEN: OK, when it
comes to code, the farther you
want me away from it is probably
best, because I start
breaking stuff.
If it's not broken, you have
me in there, I'll start
breaking it.
That's why I have a good team
to do all that stuff.
BEN: You sound like a great
QA person, actually.
VINCENT NGUYEN: Yes, yes.
I do the testing.
I do the review.
I love to just get in there
and tear things up, and
try to break it.
But as long as I don't have
to fix it, I'm good.
FITZ: So what kind of terrible
things have you done to the
awesome Nexus seven-inch
tablet that you got?
VINCENT NGUYEN: Awesome,
well--
BEN: It's only been a day.
VINCENT NGUYEN: It's
only been a day.
FITZ: Have you broken it?
Be honest.
VINCENT NGUYEN: No, I
haven't broken it.
It's a really good device.
The price is awesome.
It's fast.
And it's just really nice
and comfortable to
hold in your hand.
I don't recommend breaking it.
It's such a good device.
It's a shame.
FITZ: I totally agree
with you.
I can't wait to try out mine.
BEN: Do you have plans to
use your Q at home?
Or are you just going
to dissect it?
VINCENT NGUYEN: Well, I do
have plans to use it.
In terms of how long--
because products cycle through
every couple days for me.
I mean, I'm hoping it's one
device that I'm going to have
around for a long
period of time.
And especially with the
ecosystem I have in my house,
I've got Apple.
I've got Android.
I've got to bounce back and
forth between the two.
So it gets kind of hairy.
FITZ: So you were also on the
countdown to Android--
I mean to count down to Google
I/O. Well, you were the count
down to Android, back in
the day, I suppose.
Tell us a little
bit about that.
VINCENT NGUYEN: It
was kind of cool.
I mean, it was great to be a
part of it and to be here.
FITZ: Is it cool to have been a
part of something since day
one and all here five
years later and
see where we're going?
VINCENT NGUYEN: Absolutely.
I mean, I wouldn't
change a thing.
I mean, to be here five years
later, to see Android where it
is today and--
like I say, it's not just
being a part of--
like a historian, if you
will, we're recording
the history of Android.
But we're actively participating
in its growth.
And so, that's where
we take our pride.
BEN: Have you gotten to connect
to other people in
your community, people
who read your site?
Have you met any of them here
or any of the folks?
VINCENT NGUYEN: Funny you
should bring that up.
I mean, that's a neat thing,
because a lot of the times we
work with these developers--
reviewing their apps
and whatnot.
But to be here, and connecting
with them, and meeting them in
person, saying, hi.
You know, we've sent
a bazillion
emails back and forth.
It's great to see
you in person.
And that's when you really
connect with not just the app,
which is the medium, but the
people behind all the hard
work that goes into
these great apps.
BEN: I imagine there's a lot
opportunities there that come
out of that.
FITZ: That echoes a lot of what
we heard from our other
guests, which is that it's not
only an opportunity for great
sessions, for great hardware,
but for great connections with
other developers.
BEN: What we call the
hallway track--
FITZ: The hallway
track, exactly.
BEN: Perhaps the most important
part of any
conference.
FITZ: Yep.
Well, Ben, I think that about
wraps it up for the live
segment of Google I/O 2012.
BEN: Absolutely.
And all of these talks and key
notes will be available on
developers.google.com/io.
FITZ: Correct.
BEN: And you'll be able to
watch them all there.
FITZ: And we hope we'll
see you guys all back
right here in 2013.
Thanks.
BEN: Thank you.
FITZ: Bye.